don't get me wrong I really enjoy the
new it movies super creepy great cast
and striking imagery man does it push
the limits of believability cannibal
space clowns from outer space living in
small-town Maine fine intergalactic
space turtles puking up the universe
been there done that no problem what I'm
talking about is this mic in the movie
calls all of these people and they all
answer the phone even though he's listed
as an unknown number that has got to be
the craziest thing that happens in
either of these two movies I mean what
is this some kind of alternate universe
where there's no spam callers because if
so I want to live there even if I do
have to dodge a murder clown every
couple of decades seems like a small
price to pay hello Internet welcome to
film theory where the only it to fear is
it itself and maybe also fortune cookies
stuffed with weird eyeball monsters
today we're talking about the movie
franchise with the least optimized title
for the internet it more specifically
we're looking at the ending of it
chapter 2 which everyone of the internet
has tried to explain and which everyone
has failed in doing yeah yeah shots
fired and all that but honestly I can't
blame on the ending as its presented in
this movie is weird and confusing and
not super clear I don't think even the
directors really knew what was going on
anyway as the plot goes the main
characters perform a ritual that has a
wacky name the ritual of chewed it fails
for reasons that go completely
unexplained the scary clown then
transforms into a scary clown spider and
then a few CGI chase scenes later the
heroes are suddenly able to win through
the power of negging again through no
apparent reason that goes explained
that's a real good message by the way be
petty and mean and you can conquer the
cosmos is greatest evil but no
seriousness the ending here is just
flimsy why did the ritual of Jude fail
the first time what suddenly changed
that allowed the losers Club to suddenly
be able to defeat the clown if that
ritual was gonna end up being pointless
the entire time were the repeated fetch
quests to find tokens in the middle of
the movie a complete waste of time too
because if so please why didn't you cut
them this was nearly a three-hour movie
my bladder was about to pop at the end
of this thing but no seriousness I
didn't really have an answer for any of
these questions
neither do other videos on YouTube heck
even Stephen King's original source
material as wishy-washy on a lot of that
stuff but after seeing the movie a
couple more times this time with smaller
big gulps because I learned my lessons
I'm convinced that we all misunderstood
the big climax of the losers Club story
I've got a theory Oh Phil theory that
for all of Hettie wisest talk of the
ritual of chewed not working not only
for the losers club but also for the
ancient native tribe who tried it before
them by the end of the film the ritual
of chewed is indeed the reason he's able
to be defeated that the first failed
ritual of the club and that Pennywise is
subsequent to feat all boiled down to
two main things one the tokens that the
losers collected weren't enough to
complete the ritual and to one of them
didn't even bring the right token to the
fight that's right one of these bozos
didn't even manage to snag their token
in the first place so today let's take a
moment to find out why the losers should
have died and how they accidentally
found their way to defeating the
universe's scariest circus freak in case
you forgot or more reasonable he just
gave the ritual of chewed a big ol I
roll when you saw it chapter 2 let's
briefly recap shall we the ritual
requires each participant to bring a
token of their past trauma to its
underground lair they're then meant to
destroy the tokens in the process
trapping Pennywise or more accurately
his true form the dead lights in an
authentic tribal Lantern Mike clearly
purchased from Pier one Imports and it's
this golden ticket hunt for tokens that
sets us up on our extended sequence of
mid movie fetch quests full of naked cgi
grandmas and more over-the-top jump
scares than a five nights at freddy's
game Eddie finds his inhaler
Ritchie gets an arcade token Hill
recovers his dead brothers paper boat
Mike gets the rock that they used to
fight against the town bully in the
first movie that gets the romantic haiku
that Ben wrote for her when they were
kids and Ben reveals that he still got
the yearbook page Bev signed all those
years ago the six descended to penny
wises lair burn those items or heat up
Mike's rocks since
you know it's a rock the deadlights
descended to the lantern and then
nothing
Pennywise escapes immediately without
any level of difficulty he taunts that
the Native American tribe the Shakopee
well once used this same technique
before and that it didn't work then
either but you know at this point the
movie Mike is a guy who literally
brought all of his friends who are rich
and successful and famous back to a
bummer of a town to fight a killer
cosmic clown using a strategy that he
knew failed the first time so you know
his word is kind of garbage at this
point but still what the movie never
really answers is what went wrong for
the losers Club and for the
whatchamacallit tribe from centuries
before those are the mechanics of the
ritual of shoot after all and that's
exactly what they do so is the ritual
itself just flawed well to understand we
have to first look at what the ritual
actually means it's not just about
burning some stuff
it's about destroying your past Mike's
instructions to the group were
technically true find and destroy the
tokens of your traumatic past but he
actually missed that the point of the
ritual was to get over the things from
your past that you're afraid of because
that is what it actually feeds off of to
truly destroy the things not so much in
a physical sense but in a symbolic sense
sure the mechanics are physically
destroying things but to successfully
perform the ritual of chewed you have to
destroy the trauma associated with those
things TLDR what mike really should have
done was have the gang enroll in a lot
of therapy and then once they dealt with
their issues then come back to town to
destroy the cosmic clown but in all
seriousness if you look at these mid
movie fetch quests sure several members
of the gang face some harrowing
experiences to get their tokens but do
any of them actually overcome their
fears in the process let me save you a
thinking time no no they do not bill is
lured to a sewer by his dead brother
Georgie's voice calling for help bill
reaches in desperately trying to rescue
his brother who again is dead in the end
he fishes Georgie's boat out of the
sewer after getting attacked by
thousands of zombie baby hands so he
technically got his token but did this
experience force him to overcome the
fear and guilt that he still has about
Georgie's death no in fact it shows the
exact opposite that he's not over
Georgie's death despite being an adult
who knows that his brother is dead he
still clings to this belief that he can
somehow rescue Georgie he's living in
denial sure after that encounter he
manages to rescue the token but the
token is meaningless let's look at
another example Bev is able to grab
Ben's postcard from the hiding spot in
her old home but the apartment is still
haunted literally by her history in the
history event but also figuratively by
the specter of fathers both Pennywise
and Bev's own father like Bill she
doesn't actually confront her fears here
she's just confronted by a giant naked
CGI woman she literally runs for her
life running away from Pennywise running
away from that old woman running away
from her father all of it without
achieving any sort of closure on her
childhood abuse
same goes Freddy faces the leper in the
basement of the pharmacy symbol of his
old hypochondria he does what he needs
to do to grab his inhaler token and then
immediately runs away from the shop
afraid Ritchie grabs his literal token
of a token from the arcade which
honestly has almost nothing to do with
his secret shame of being gay something
that we're gonna touch on more here in a
minute most of his token getting takes
place in flashbacks so he's not even
dealing with his fears in real time at
least until the end of the scene where
he finally also runs away from Pennywise
in broad daylight in the middle of a
public park he tells himself that
Pennywise isn't real but when he opens
his eyes no Pennywise is still there
meaning that the fear is still there
showing pretty clearly that Ritchie
still has demons that he doesn't want to
talk about even Ben and Mike the two
losers who already had their tokens
haven't really gotten over the fears
that those tokens represent Ben whose
token is the yearbook page that only
Beverly signed has literally been
carrying that page with him every day of
his life
let me rephrase that he's carrying a
symbol of his loneliness and unrequited
love on his person for over 20 years
doesn't get more not
over it than that and as we see in the
opening scenes of the movie adult Ben is
still a loner sure he's super rich and
successful but he's at home he's alone
in his massive house refusing to attend
meetings in person he's isolated just
like he was when he was a kid isolated
and even when given the chance mid movie
still hiding his true feelings about bed
still allowing her to think that it was
bill who wrote her that poem so many
years ago and then there's Mike showing
up with his rock which honestly makes
sense but what is the true essence of
that token Mike's issue in the first
movie was that he was shunned as an
outcast and even though it seems like
he's been integrated into the town of
Derry he hasn't he's the only one in
town who knows what's happening and who
hasn't forgotten his own past making him
an outsider he's also the only member of
the losers Club to stay back in Derry
thereby making him an outsider again but
this time to his very own friends the
losers and then he lies to the whole
group about the ritual of chood he tells
them that the ritual has worked in the
past but it hasn't and that truth
doesn't come out until Pennywise spills
the beans at the end of the movie Mike
is ashamed and afraid to admit the truth
to his friends clearly he doesn't feel
like he belongs here so now that we've
seen how the losers have overcome
practically nothing by the end of the
second half of this movie it becomes a
little clearer why their token burning
during the final battle isn't effective
these objects are still just that
they're objects they're hollow they're
meaningless so when they burn nothing
happens and so when Pennywise pops out
and all his spider clown glory it's not
a shot the ritual doesn't work because
they didn't believe there was no
substance behind what they were doing
and instead of getting rid of their
problems all they've gotten rid of are a
couple of pieces of moldy paper and an
old shower cap so then how do the losers
end up winning what changes between this
moment at the end of the movie
well now the gang actually has to get
over their issues and they have to do it
in a hurry and that's why the entire
next sequence of the movie is all about
the losers Club yet again going on
secret personal missions about their
past trauma only this time when they're
forced to confront that trauma they get
over
for Mike Pennywise already outed him so
as soon as he confesses to the group
that he was actually lying about the
ritual of Jude and starts being an
actual team player well Mike's in the
clear his friends learned the truth they
didn't abandon him boom his token
suddenly has meaning the others in this
sequence are a bit more complicated Ben
and Bev have to go through everyone's
two worst fears getting buried alive and
having to touch anything in a public
restroom Ben is finally forced to let go
that torch he's been carrying for Bev
all those years to avoid being literally
buried in his past while Bev confronts
herself as an adult and lets go of her
adolescent trauma so she can reach out
in a literal and figurative sense to
make another human connection with Ben
bill meanwhile has to shoot himself with
a sheep dart which is just a weird weird
moment that I don't want to linger
around for risk of de monetization but
suffice it to say that the thing is
actually killing isn't a person it's his
guilt and shame over the loss of his
brother
so with those four finally overcoming
their issues we cut back to the fight to
find Eddie and Ritchie still mostly
avoiding their problems literally
running away again from the scary not
scary doors and then Ritchie gets caught
in the deadlines suddenly Eddy whose
fears this entire time have been
imaginary diseases from his hypochondria
has to finally decide what the real
danger in his life is as a child he was
told that everything was dangerous so
overcoming his fear naturally involves
the realization that it actually is all
in his head that loved ones being in
trouble is the real thing to fear here
he convinces himself that the spear he's
holding will damage Pennywise and he
throws it and it does which shows us
that Eddy now understands that he
controls his own fate that what he
believes is true can become a reality
and in the process Eddy manages to save
Ritchie
unfortunately for Eddy though it wasn't
all in his head since it turns around
and impales Eddy making the official
tally it thousands losers Club still
zero
but what Pennywise doesn't realise is
that he's inadvertently sacrificed the
last token on behalf of the losers Club
because Eddy is Ritchie's true to
remember what I said that we'd come back
to this later well Richie is the most
interesting case out of all the losers
Club because not only has he not fully
gotten over his fear he's never really
owned up to it in either movie in the
first place
Richie's secret is that he's gay but
we're shown at the beginning of the
movie that dairy is not exactly a woke
environment we see that Richie never
talks about being gay he actively hides
it even masquerades as a straight guy in
a stand-up routine
so my girlfriend caught me a lightning
observing her friend's Facebook page
during his treasure hunt midway through
the movie he picks up a literal token
from an arcade which sure is associated
with a painful memory of being bullied
but the real token of his fear isn't a
thing it's a person when Eddie
sacrifices himself for Richie down in
penny wises caverns Richie finally
realizes how much he truly loved Eddie
and how much their friendship has
mattered to both of them the death of
Eddie is surprisingly also the
destruction of the last token Richie's
token in Eddie's death Richie for the
first time sees that you should show how
you feel without fear shame and regret
and with that suddenly all tokens are
properly destroyed all fears are
properly overcome Pennywise by killing
Eddie delivers the thing that the losers
Club needed in order to complete the
ritual of chewed this time the right way
he it inverted does himself in if you
think it's still a stretch that Eddie is
the real final token here well look no
further than the moments leading up to
Richie being caught the dead lights
Richie goes up and starts actively
insulting Pennywise to its face and it
does nothing
hey Lane person what Richard err you're
a sloppy doodoo head Pennywise is
getting insulted here and yet he is not
affected by it in the slightest but if
we fast forward exactly four minutes
later in the movie the losers defeat him
using the exact same technique insulting
the clown to death so what happened in
between those two moments the only major
change to happen in that four-minute
span is Eddie's death the book and the
movie of it have pretty different
representations of the ritual of Jude
and all the events leading up to it but
there
one piece of the story that remains true
in both versions the losers can't defeat
it until Eddie dies he dies the same way
in both versions - and after he does and
only after he does are the losers able
to defeat it either by punching
Pennywise to death like in the book or
verbally abusing him to death until he's
like a deflated balloon like in the
movie everything else around the ritual
can change but Eddie's death has to
remain in the story because it's his act
of love that helps Richie overcome his
fears the movie closes with Richie
finishing the carving he made when he
was younger
r+ II with the message that you should
be who you want to be and be proud and
that my friends is how Pennywise
defeated himself and what everyone
including the losers Club themselves
misunderstood about the ending of it
chapter 2 but hey that's just a theory
Oh
film theory
[Music]